né en Russie l'ancien espion du kgbcrj
gearnov est un habitué de notre plateau
mais aussi de la chaîne LCI où il
intervient régulièrement bonjour Serge
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
sur elleci mais depuis le 15 septembre
l'été spectateurs de la chaîne du groupe
TF1 on remarqué son absence en cause
cette phrase prononcée en direct
c'est un héros il était colonel mais
c'est une [ __ ]
[Musique]
avait déjà fait polémique en août
dernier avec cette imitation c'est Dieu
sait s'il fait peur voilà alors une
imitation qui avait choqué certains
téléspectateurs et qui avaient poussé la
chaîne à s'excuser en direct tout
d'abord ces excuses après la séquence ou
notre chroniqueur Serge a imité un agent
chinois avec cette nouvelle polémique
survenue il y a quelques jours la chaîne
a donc pris la décision de l'évincé une
pétition a été mise en ligne pour
réclamer son retour sur LCI alors après
avoir insulté Vladimir Poutine
comprenez-vous que LCI a décidé de virer
Serge
et Sergueï et je le dis tu étais chez
l'excellent Darius Rochebin trouve
formidable il est exceptionnel non mais
sérieux il est très très fort
parce que lui très très bon mais
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé mon sérieux je
te sens tout tout tout tout tout tout
tout pas bien là
bah non je suis ravi d'être parmi vous
après c'est un ça s'est passé que ils
m'ont remercié je te remercie merci
quand on dit quoi comment ça s'est passé
juste après ça donc en fait ça s'est
passé le 14 sur le plateau de de
LCI on parlait de Poutine et à un moment
donné il y a un mot qui m'échappe comme
ça pour moi je voulais dire c'est un
lâche donc tu le regrettes bien
évidemment je l'ai mis d'ailleurs sur
sur les plateaux en fait c'est un mot et
directement sur le plateau parce que
Eric bonnet il a j'ai vu quand même que
il a réagi d'une manière un peu
bizarroïde je me suis dit peut-être j'ai
dit quelque chose de trop fort mais pour
moi je connaissais pas le troisième le
troisième sens de ce mot d'ailleurs
j'étais au dîner avec des amis je
racontais cette histoire il y avait une
française de souche qui a dit mais il
est où le problème elle savait pas non
plus ça veut dire qu'il moi je suis
étranger c'est pas mal en maternelle
d'ailleurs je lui ai dit tout de suite
sur sur le plateau il m'arrive
d'employer bien évidemment ça fait
plaisir de parler de montrer que on
parle bien parce que je commençais à
prendre le français à 18 ans voilà et
donc que j'arrive à écrire les livres en
français il y a les livres qui marchent
etc mais il m'arrive aussi de ne pas
savoir exactement ce que ce que mot un
mot peut signifier et je l'ai dit sur le
plateau et donc il y a
Juliette qui a repris tout de suite en
me disant bon bah on accepte vos excuses
l'incident que l'eau bon après je suis
convoqué chez le directeur qui Fabien
Damien
et on a passé une demi-heure donc voilà
ils m'ont dit écoutez il y a une
connotation différente par rapport à ce
mot donc on sait traiter bien que vous
êtes trompé tout simplement donc en fait
on a passé on a passé une conversation
très franche tout en sachant que il m'a
dit voilà c'est si c'était vraiment du
pour chercher le buzz on c'est une
acceptable mais là c'est une bourde en
fait à tout le monde et elle arrive de
faire des bruits en fait ah d'accord
et donc du coup
et du coup
j'ai pas entendu
et
ils m'ont dit voilà on vous
pendant une semaine vous serez pas à
l'antenne ah ouais et vous revenez le 26
et donc il était venu aujourd'hui il
était venu chez nous aujourd'hui
entre-temps et aujourd'hui je vais
revenir à l'antenne et donc pour ne pas
passer tout simplement une semaine à
Paris à faire à ce morphon bien sûr donc
j'ai eu j'ai pris des vacances parce
qu'en même temps il y a tous les gens
qui me suivent sur les réseaux qui me
demandaient on vous vaut plus à
l'antenne qu'est-ce qui se passe etc et
donc j'ai pas voulu non plus mettre ça
sur sur la place publique je suis passé
en Normandie j'ai publié quelques photos
sur sur la plage et le 21 décembre il y
a Poutine qui fait sa déclaration donc
il est une annonce quasiment la
troisième guerre mondiale la troisième
guerre mondiale donc mon téléphone il
commence à sonner le matin donc je
reçois 1000 appels donc il y a tous les
médias qui veulent avoir
la vie donc je donne des interviews à la
presse écrite à la radio
et vous m'appelez bien sûr en disant
Sergueï je te veux ce soir chez nous sur
le plateau je te veux pour la vie
voilà
tu es venu chez nous en premier ou chez
eux à l'époque
et Marion en France en réalité ici ah
oui ici et donc tu reviennes nous voir
alors qu'ils t'ont découvert chez nous
ce qui t'ont découvert chez nous
alors je voulais je vous explique les
méthodes LCI donc il y a un mec qui
vient ici qu'on découvre dont tout le
monde parle parce que quand c'est gay
est venu tout le monde a dit il est
exceptionnel et c'est là vraiment sa
première télé c'est sa première télé à
groupe où il y a eu énormément de
publics vraiment qui ont déjà tu te dis
SCI prend juste l'oseille parce que
personne te regarde ils font 0 %
d'ambiance
qui t'a dit je t'ai vu sur LCI est-ce
que tu peux me dire est-ce que tu as
déjà vu un mec dans la rue que tu as dit
sur LCI
ça va vous étonner mais oui
tu as déjà eu tu as pas des mecs qui te
disent plus on t'a vu chez TPMP que sur
LCI bien évidemment il y a les jeunes
qui me reconnaissent plus parce
les méthodes elles sont très simples ça
veut dire c'est une énorme marquage le
gars vient ici hein il vient il voit que
ça cartonne et le lendemain il l'appelle
tiens ce que tu veux venir chez nous
donc quand même
le soir même après une fois qu'il est
venu chez moi quoi est-ce que les gars
les gars je te jure mais eux c'est parce
que eux je vais vous dire c'est tout par
derrière c'est que des coups en douce
non mais c'est vrai c'est que des cons
donc il appelle par derrière alors que
il était chez nous il appelle juste
après l'émission est-ce que tu veux
venir chez nous donc oui il y va au
début il va tranquille hein après il dit
bon tu vas venir tout le temps et il
revient ici pour faire ils vont nous
parler voilà de la déclaration Poutine
et là ils disent non en fait tu peux
plus revenir parce que tu as été chez
nous alors qu'ils ont découvert chez
nous eux c'est toujours comme ça
et encore de manière détourner parce que
c'est même pas le mot
je te le dis c'est pas du tout ça c'est
parce que tu es venu ici ne crois pas
ouais je te le dis ça ça y est ça
s'était réglé tu avais fait ta semaine
de de de purgatoire et puis tu as l'air
de venir à l'antenne là ils sont dit
comme tu es venu chez nous ils sont dit
le moment on va le on va le dégager mais
tu crois que je connais très bien leur
méthode sache-le et voilà c'est je vais
te dire ce sont des gens qui n'ont pas
de courage tu vois ça que tu aurais dû
dire tu vois ils n'ont pas de courage
ils sont comme Poutine comme tu as voulu
mais c'est vrai tu as voulu c'est ce que
tu voulais dire sur Poutine qui manque
de courage
ils sont toujours dès qu'ils viennent
devant toi ils te font des courbettes
des trucs et tu sais que quoi qu'il
arrive quand ils te disent bonjour tu
sais qu'ils vont te [ __ ] mais quand
ils te disent bonjour avec une table
dans le dos tu sais qu'ils t'ont déjà
[ __ ]
non mais c'est que des gars comme ça non
mais c'est insupportable et c'est ça et
en fait et quand tu vas au fight avec
lui dis ouais mais c'est lui qui m'a
attaqué vous savez c'est comme le gars
en classe qui te fait chier qui te fait
chier qui te fait chier à un moment tu
lui mets une tarte dans la gueule ouais
c'est ce qui m'est arrivé et après
maintenant ça fait deux heures que tu me
casses les couilles voilà c'est tout
c'est mal c'est pareil voilà mais c'est
c'est insupportable et ce sont les
méthodes de LCI et une fois voilà et toi
tu as été pris en otage encore c'est
insupportable oui non moi je suis
d'accord avec vous sur les méthodes
après dire que Poutine est une [ __ ] à
l'antenne c'est quand même compliqué en
vrai ici
donc moi en fait moi j'adore ça et je
trouve que vous êtes très bon mais plus
le temps mais tu as entendu ces
explications oui mais bon c'est quand
même sur une chaîne info et moi j'ai du
mal à savoir en fait si vous êtes un
exception du KGB spécialiste de la
Russie ou si parfois vous êtes pas un
peu là pour faire le chaud de plus de
médiatique moi je me rappelle du tout
quand il est venu quand il est venu la
semaine dernière il nous a expliqué il
nous a tourné très bon on a fait le show
la semaine dernière non pas du tout on
était très sérieux et bien sûr
d'ailleurs il était très à l'aéroports
[Applaudissements]
à chaque fois que vous venez il y a des
déclarations qui font polémiques c'est
tout c'est mais alors merci
parce qu'il est incroyable en télé c'est
un monstre Game c'est une star voilà
Raymond non moi je suis pas d'accord
avec Guillaume parce que ok il s'est
trompé de mots parce qu'il pensait que
ça voyait notre signification il a il
maîtrise pas la langue française c'est
pas sa langue maternité
souvenez-vous il était spectateur TPMP
ils sont témoin souvenez-vous comment il
a dégoupillé les premières fois qu'il
est venu sur sur Poutine il a dégoupillé
plus que ça il a dit des trucs encore
pire que ça c'est ils le prennent parce
que c'est une grande gueule et parce
qu'il est un truc choc sur TPMP tiens
viens il va dire des trucs chocs chez
nous et dès qu'il se trompe de mots
allez hop on le vient on le dégage bien
sûr net c'est pas honnête de faire ça
vous l'avez pris parce que c'était une
grande gueule ils l'ont pris parce qu'il
disait des mots sur Poutine
souvenez-vous ici ce qu'il a dit sur
Poutine
non mais il est vrai qu'il faut quand
même lutter contre la banalisation des
insultes homophobes
c'est essentiel on est d'accord oui faut
pas laisser passer de toute façon
il a été sanctionné s'excuser et après
on le reprend
il l'a fait Bernard il s'est bien
compris propos inadmissible sanction non
mais là il nous a fait le truc RFM là
c'est voilà merci il a été il a été
sanctionné Bernard quand vous êtes
sanctionné après on peut discuter une
semaine qu'un jour ok il est sanctionné
après vous savez très bien que c'est de
l'hypocrisie bien sûr c'est double peine
qu'on lui inflige c'est-à-dire vous êtes
sanctionné une première fois et
maintenant définitivement parce qu'il
est revenu ça c'est pas admissible alors
que cette semaine là il bouillonnait je
le sais très bien je l'ai vu il était
comme une théière il y avait plein
d'infos qui circulaient il est venu là
s'exprimer c'était hyper intéressant et
on le bâillonne après définitivement sur
LCI ça ça va passer comme un jambon
Bayonne
je trouve ça honteux de supprimer le
travail
[Musique]
que pour essayer que pour les chaînes
info
à l'exception de la promotion de mes
livres donc si j'avais la promotion de
mes livres à faire j'avais même
l'autorisation d'aller sur les chaînes
ici je pouvais aller comme je voulais
d'ailleurs je suis venu à plusieurs
reprises ici quand j'étais sur une
chaîne animaux
donc là il y a il y avait aucun problème
et c'est ça ça posait la seule fois où
ça a posé le problème c'est la semaine
dernière alors justement alors je
rappelle si vous nous rejoignez
l'affaire cerisier
il fait des missions ici c'était l'an
dernier il est incroyable tout le monde
m'envoie des sms ce garçon est
incroyable je veux je veux je veux son
livre tout le monde m'envoie des DM tout
le monde m'envoie des messages te
concernant il est formidable il est
formidable il est formidable et
tout le monde a vu qui était formidable
même LCI parce qu'elle s'est il appelle
le soir même il lui dit est-ce que tu
veux venir chez nous donc voilà donc il
nous le pique
bien raison d'y aller tu étais payé je
comprends tout à fait l'aspect pikuni je
ne te jette pas la pierre et ensuite ils
acceptent pas qu'ils reviennent ici
juste en invité voilà nous voir pour
nous expliquer la déclaration de
Vladimir Poutine oui Benjamin à propos
des invités entre le groupe TF1 et nous
il y a souvent des invités qui ont dit
vous venez d'abord chez nous c'est non
on ne vous prend pas c'est un c'est
monnaie cours on ne s'arrives tout le
temps tout le temps qu'il refuse et ceux
qui acceptent c'est-à-dire que s'ils
vont ici il y a des invités
excuse-moi on dirait qu'on est au
citoyen
il y a une vieille guerre en fait entre
le groupe TF1 ce qui raconte et vous
c'est qu'il y a souvent les invités qui
sont invités on arrivait là vous venez
chez nous mais si vous allez chez
Hanouna avant on vous prend pas d'accord
ça c'est que c'est plus c'est plus clair
vous avez compris maintenant
sauf avant le lancement de cette
deuxième partie je vous ai dit vous
savez ce qui s'est passé avec notre
équipe merci heureusement que tu suis
l'émission toi alors
et donc normalement sur les quatre
chaînes TV c'est BFM qui est première
bien sûr LCI 2e non non non
22 minuit à partir de moi de mai on est
premier non systématiquement parce que
je vous le dis la première chaîne
d'infos c'est BFM après ces cynews et
BFM excellente Apolline de Malherbe
ensuite c'est cnews ensuite c'est voilà
LCI France Info c'est à peu près voilà
c'est à peu près voilà c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est derrière ça ça c'est c'est
voilà
on comprend on comprend votre
explication
et le problème aussi c'est que en fait
au mois de mai quand c'est arrivé
quand c'est arrivé la première fois je
disais mais c'est parce que c'est Éric
prenait un grand journaliste etc parce
que il est connu etc bon ok il part en
vacances en été donc il est remplacé par
Darius Rochebin excellent Dargus on
reste toujours à la même chose après
Darius et les remplacer par d'autres
personnes pendant l'été non et tous
l'été avec les remplaçants on est resté
les numéros qui était là tout le temps
c'est moi c'est toi
j'en sais rien mais bon voilà il y a pas
je vais te dire il y a pas de hasard à
partirry
[Rires]
pour aller danser et donc tu es quoi là
aujourd'hui tu étais vénère
en fait ils choisissent les gens qui
peuvent résister au 13 moi je résiste
parfaitement au stress j'ai trois
bouquins qui marchent j'ai deux bouquins
qui sont les best-sellers je vis très
très bien avec ma bouquin
c'est pas une question de melon j'ai
répondu hier à une amie dans le film que
j'adore c'est le cap se rebiffe c'est du
Michel Audiard et Michel Audiard en fait
dans ce dans ce film Gabin qui dit une
phrase par rapport à son à un jeune de
talent qui récupère et lui dit mon petit
ne pas reconnaître ses qualités c'est
laisser la place aux médiocre
c'est du audience
[Applaudissements]
compétition enfin un truc abominable
raciste SOS Racisme il faut avancer ça
et en plus ils ont repris le clip ils
l'ont mis sur le réseau leur propre
réseau en disant qu'on veut des excuses
et leur retrait de du clip et moi je
leur ai répondu si les excuses je
voulais je voulais présente mais en
revanche vous avez mis votre propre clip
sur votre propre chaîne donc le demander
de le retirer sur la NCI il faut quand
même savoir ce que vous voulez donc soit
vous le relayez et à ce moment-là il
s'impose aucun problème soit vous le
demandez de le retirer mais à ce
moment-là vous le montrez pas oui mais
ça a publié des gens ça vous pouvez et
après si vous êtes excusé d'ailleurs et
après j'ai pas dit j'ai mis des excuses
formelles ça ça a pu heurter notre nos
amis chinois etc ou orientaux donc je
présente mes études bien évidemment etc
donc là non plus vous savez mais Michel
Leeb
vous souvenez du YouTube
il a il a évolué avec l'époque il faut
autre chose maintenant
en fait la réaction par rapport au truc
chinois la réaction était mais on peut
plus rien dire actuellement Coluche
c'est l'été là il serait en prison
monsieur
de l'euro s'il était là il serait en
prison on peut on peut on peut plus
raconter des blagues il faut être de la
communauté sera pour raconter ses
blagues sur soi-même parce que sinon
vous êtes accès tout de suite de racisme
d'homophobe etc etc voilà et euh
en revanche ce truc là avec Poutine
personne n'a repris vous êtes les seuls
vous êtes les seuls vous êtes les seuls
à l'avoir mis en par écrit c'est pas ou
parce que tous les autres ils ont ils
ont eu des proches parce que
pour monter la sauce il fallait dire
monsieur gernov a traité Poutine de de
ça ils ont ils ont pas eu les
c'est pas ouf
ok mais Géraldine question bon aussi
parce que en fait partager parce que je
pense que l'époque est quand même très
très compliqué parce qu'on est dans une
sorte de génération de minorité tout le
temps comment dire choquée ou fusquer
donc effectivement quand on est deux
heures on dirait quelqu'un et qu'on le
vire après parce qu'il est venu chez
nous
parce que c'est le vrai truc c'est ça en
fait sort de fuite des talons comme ça
on va prendre des gens on va faire
plutôt non mais de la même manière que
est-ce que vous vous accepteriez par
exemple que nous on aille le soir sur
BFM
[Rires]
vous l'avez dit justement je pense que
les téléspectateurs ont entendu j'ai
réglé nous aussi on a un contrat bien
sûr en revanche on a le droit d'aller
ailleurs par exemple sur la proposition
de nos
pas contrario si je peux vous sucer
stérile c'est que Cyril il vous le dit
directement il vous vire il passe pas
par un truc
texto dans la seconde dans la seconde
langage
tous les deux le problème aussi vous
avez parlé de de compétences hier sur le
plateau de Darius dans dans ma tronche
j'ai été remplacé par un étudiant de 22
ans il est sympa il est très sympa il
est très intelligent mais sauf que il a
pas vécu 40 ans ce que moi j'ai vécu il
a pas connu Poutine il a pas servi comme
supérieur du KGB il connaît rien dans la
Russie d'ailleurs je crois que il a
jamais mis les pieds dans dans ce pays
et voilà je suis remplacé par un
étudiant de 22 ans merci
pour il était déjà dans une sauce non
mais c'est vrai oui
38%, non voilà voilà donc non tu vois
61% tu as vu
je suis triste un peu parce qu'en fait
maintenant tu es devenu une star là tout
le monde te veut
j'essaie de rester quand même calme et
tourne pas pour ne pas voler dans les
mais ce qui est marrant c'est qu'ils ont
fait il y a quelqu'un qui a mis la la
pétition le retour de 19 il y a déjà
2000 personnes d'ailleurs là il y a 2
millions
donc à mon avis demain il y aura
peut-être un million
calme-toi quand même calme-toi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]